và các đời tác thúc đẩy phát triển nông nghiệp bình bứng tại Tây Nguyen.
Nghe 20% năm 2018, nhằm năng cao vai trò phủ nữ trong nông nghiệp,
may ở đáp với hợp với chung tâm quyến nông và Simeex Cô đặc lắc xả mắc câu lật bộ nữ đại sự
cà phê bình bứng.
Phà đậm nằm trong khu khổ dự án, bây giờ, là em phà mình,
sang kiến toàn cầu của bà yên em hỗ trợ nông dân tình quyền ứng dụ cạnh tác bình bứng,
tích ứng với biến đổi khi hậu.
Cô lặc bộ hủ đình kết nối, trong bị kinh thức kinh tác và chăm sóc su quay cho các nữ nhản nông,
dù họ tự tin phát hề tiêm năng, năng cao xin kế và thúc đẩy phát triển cộng đồng biến bứng.
Sự kiến dễn dành dịp kiến nghiệp năm 2018,
đức với sự tham dự của biến sĩ Zos快, và lát, tổng lãnh dự đất.
Trong chuyến tham, biến sĩ, và lát có cơ hội cho đổi cùng các nông dân địa phương và đối tác trong chủi ra chỉ nông nghiệp đề hiểu só hơn,
và nhìn thấy thức só biến đổi khi hậu và các bánh đề trong chủi cùng ứng.
Mà sii lên dù mất, tổng ra đốc bài hồ Việt Nam cho biết,
bài hồ luôn cảm kết đồng hành cùng nhảnh nông Việt Nam thuộc đẩy phát triển đông nghiệp biến bứng.
Các sáng kính của chúng tôi không chỉ hướng đến nâng cao năng sớt kinh tác mà còn mong muốn cải tiện sức khoải và chất lượng cuộc sống cho người nông dân và dây đi học.
Thông qua những sáng kinh thích thực và sự phối hợp chặt chẽ với các đối tác liệu phương,
bài hồ đá và đăng đồng hành cùng Việt Nam sẽ sửa một nền nông nghiệp sáng, hề đại pháp viên bước.